my discussion today i want to emphasize
is really a very basic introduction to
the issues that anybody who was thinking
about personal digital archiving needs
to keep in mind we live in a world where
we're rapidly assembling growing amounts
of information in different formats
we're creating we're collecting we're
building gigantic collections of
material for ourselves and we're storing
that material in many different places
whether it be on our laptop whether it
be in the cloud whether it be on a host
of different handheld devices or or
recording instruments this vast array of
material reflects the fact that we are
the latest agent has been a long
historic evolution of great leaps
forward in communications technology and
each of those steps has taken us forward
a quantum leap each time in terms of
greater flop our flexibility reach and
tragically somewhat greater
vulnerability of materials so the
problem with digital media is that
without mediation digital data is not
much used to most of us I couldn't
resist showing this small detail of a
portrait of andrew andy warhol which i
think he would appreciate shown to you
without mediation and it shows how
useless this material can be without
that mediation that vulnerability though
expresses itself in far less amusing
ways for example the potential for
disaster of all kinds the sort of whom
fire the flood the spilled coffee the
theft of our dissertation from the back
seat of our card gets reported every
couple of years the horrible virus that
lands on our computer and destroys
everything but more than that the
potential for obsolescence I'm showing
some of the most burning examples of
media that has ceased to be useful but
every day I can assure you new media is
going out of date new types of storage
devices new types of hardware that are
not very important anymore and add to
that the fact that data sitting quietly
on the shelf in our offices often just
slowly decaying and when we go back to
it a few years later we can no longer
read it and
then there are those like myself who
know they have the file somewhere but if
it's not organized what good does it do
so the object of my discussion today is
to suggest that we all seize the day and
this is a perhaps a rather grim image
but it suggests i think the urgency of
the problem that most of us are facing i
suspect that all of us do some kind of
job to preserve our data but i'd be
willing to bet that most of us don't do
nearly what we need to do to preserve it
and the tragedy is that at the base of
this are really some just basic good
habits along the line of you should
exercise frequently you should eat
healthy foods there are a set of best
practices that are emerging and it's for
that reason that this group has come
together at Columbia to try to help
people to think about archiving their
digital data and I want to just talk
really basically about the baseline of
what is involved there so let's go ahead
and take a look in terms of the basic
concepts it's important to remember when
you're talking about saving these you're
talking about saving your files you're
not talking about saving the media
forget about that USB Drive it's going
to be dead in a couple of years forget
about that DVD forget about the places
where it's stored your files if they
have a long healthy life are going to
pass on as cyber objects to a completely
different environment somewhere else
there's another issue that we need to
think about there are two pieces to this
process most of us probably all back up
our data from time to time I hope we do
so that your dissertation isn't on just
that one laptop so it can be stolen from
the back of your car unless that's what
you really are hoping for but there's
also the question of archiving that
longer-term storage maybe you don't need
every state of your dissertation maybe
you don't need every photo that you took
of your family on their vacation you
need to to pull things out you might
also not want to store it I'll say a bit
more about this in a moment things in
formats that are used by the software
you currently have another piece of the
process you need to think about is who
are you saving for your saving for
yourself right now and often only you
will care about having the materials you
are using for writing that article there
are other things on your computer you
probably never want
down to another generation but there are
other things that you probably do things
that are going to be of lasting value
whether for your for the scholarly
community or for your family and that's
what archiving is all about it's
thinking about the long term it's
thinking about the time that you won't
be around and somebody else will need to
figure out what is there and so the next
the next point that's a little related
to that that you want to think about it
in terms of archiving there are light
archives and their dark archives you'll
have archives where you want to go back
to the shelf pull something off and get
it to work because it's died on your
machine but there'll also be an archive
perhaps where you want to keep things
quietly and untouched and often those
will be stored in formats that you can't
use so regularly particular when you
talk about things like video and other
kinds of media one thing that most
people who talk about digital archiving
suggests and it's the kind of thing that
I just think oh gosh I can't do this is
that you should write an explicit
archiving policy for yourself sitting
down and putting it I don't want to say
on paper because that's not where you
put any more putting it on your computer
is a good idea to really tell yourself
it's a chance to do an inventory what if
you got to save what do you want to save
where do you want to save it when do you
want to save it and how do you want to
save it this is a tiny little suggestion
of a one of a sort of very low level
sample text policy that Alyssa Croskey
who used to be with us at bar nerd put
together for a workshop she was doing
talking about how she decides what she's
going to save or not once you get your
materials though off of the devices you
have the minute your job is to organize
them and there are several pieces to
keep in mind obviously I think the goal
is to get one consolidated archive don't
have it on multiple devices secondly you
want to try as much as possible to get
things into uniform formats and open
formats now mind you if these are things
you're going to take back and use with
your current software you don't need to
care about that but when you're talking
about things to share with others you
want to talk about open formats what do
I mean by open formats we're talking
about things that are not dependent on a
single software to see so the simplest
way of talking about that not a docx
file but a text file or an open
text document file a file perhaps with
some markup not perhaps an Excel
spreadsheet but a comma delimited
version of that spreadsheet that can be
passed on to future generations without
depending on a particular software you
also want to come up with a clear and
logical file on directory structure
those of you who are using personal
bibliographic software may find that a
good way to at least start
conceptualising about how your research
comes together in a particular file
another important thing is coming up
with self-explanatory file naming
conventions I think we've all seen two
years after the fact that would have
been nicer if we really told ourselves
what that file was but think of how your
camera outputs things that are just
numbers you want to come up with
something that not only you but somebody
later if you want to preserve this for a
long time will be able to understand
another thing is to try to document as
much as possible where this came from
how it was created the parameters that
may be important for using it later the
more you get into multimedia the more
important this becomes it's all talking
about what is sometimes fearsomely
referred to as metadata but there's a
low level of this just to keep track of
where you got it and some of the
documentation I'll show you later and
help you decide how much metadata you
need you can often extract it from the
data you have to the other thing you
want to do when you're organizing is get
rid of the unneeded clutter that's the
stuff that's going to prevent you from
seeing what was most important there so
let's go on and talk about that once you
put it in your archive you can't just
leave it there you've got to keep it
alive that data is going to die if it's
just left alone in a corner to suck its
thumb part of that in that ensuring and
maintaining is of course have a regular
established backup and maintenance
calendar some of you may have that
hardwired in yourself I don't I have to
write those things down for myself so
that my google calendar will tell me
it's the data backup but there's a
there's another thing that you want to
do you certainly don't want have just
one copy for my sense of security and I
think a lot of people suggest that you
won't have three copies of your stuff
that way is when one of them dies you
don't have to panic that you only have
one copy of your archive left and don't
keep them in the same place maybe one in
the cloud another on a hard drive if you
have a huge computer you can have one
on your own computer but i actually
prefer to hard drives instead another
suggestion is that you need to replace
your storage media fairly often and it
seems to be that the standard rule of
thumb is every five years as a safe way
to look but you're going to be checking
on your data from time to time just if
you need to do it sooner you also
particularly for me to media need to
think about migrating formats forward as
software changes it may become the fact
that you can still convert from this
version to the next and if you don't
hurry up you can still do it again but
if you don't convert after that point
you may find you've got a little lost
piece of of media that is hard to use
with anything else and for those things
that you really want to share with
others be sure to think about an
institutional repository option for
yourself whether it be something at a
place like Columbia runs or something
that your professional organization runs
the Library of Congress spells us out a
different way but I think if we just
take down this list we can see the same
things what you need to do is identify
your data then what you need to do is
decide what you're going to save then
you need to export it from those devices
then you need to organize it and lastly
you need to manage copy and manage that
data to work with it now the devil is in
the details these are wonderful
principles I've suggested it's going to
be different for each one of you and
thankfully two members of our team Heidi
Winston and Dina sokolova have done a
great job of identifying some of the
online sites where you can find
interesting information about how to
deal with these issues it doesn't this
the soft the page does not yet have a
permanent home so I have parked it
temporarily on the digital humanities
center page there's just a link here to
personal digital archiving when you
click on that link it will take you
through after some blah blah for me to a
page where you get this information and
these tabs give you an idea of what's
here and I just want to close by telling
you these are the topics you need to be
thinking about and this is where you can
get some good detail an overview of the
best practices the kinds of things I've
talked about presented in a much more
articulate fashion the issues that one
needs to think about in dealing with
different media
type whether it be video audio
spreadsheets text photographs and on and
on some good links to talk about
techniques and tools for backing up and
recovering your data some sites that
help to assess some of the online
storage options that are out there and
to try to rank them and talk about the
issues you need to think about when
you're picking a good one a nice set of
tools for doing some batch file renaming
to make your photographs much more
intelligible to a future generation and
some tools for extracting the kind of
metadata documentation about your files
from the the files themselves next to
last a a set of listings of what the
best open file formats open file formats
are sadly there isn't one consensus
about these things and it's constantly
changing but the page can help you to
decide what's going to be best for you
and lastly a set of tools that will help
you to convert those things as you move
along so that's all that I want to say
right now my colleagues are going to
tell you a little bit more in detail
about some of the issues that we've
discussed here today
so the main question than the u.s. is
what happened to my filed ten years from
now you know and there's two brought two
things that might happen with it you
just can find it it's there or it's just
not there this is a yeah what so the
answer my answer about to personal
digital archiving is a little different
than the mainstream because I i consider
archiving and the research process to be
intertwined with each other they don't
happen at separate moments they happen
simultaneously so it's important to
always at least for me to keep that in
mind as I am working on any particular
research project that that there's
archiving issues involved this is the
typical one would you start your
research and then you store it somewhere
what I'm calling archiving there and
then you start drafting your paper the
the results of your research and then
you can't find that thing that you were
looking for and like I said it's either
because I it's there and you can't find
it or you lost it so two things two
keywords that I want you to take home
with you it's a organization and
preservation and there in two
intertwined we're going to talk about
them separately but I i want you to
reunite them in your head later
organization preservation so
organization means mostly that you want
to see a future version of yourself
searching for something so you don't
have to associate it with an
obsessive-compulsive disorder or any of
these things it's just a little bit of
futurology so the way that we organize a
list the way that I organiza is by
making sure that I have enough
information around any particular object
that I'm working with so I thought that
this talk was meant mostly for
undergraduate so I kind of fix this one
was explaining what metadata is but I in
case you needed a refresher here is
where you add information about other
information so there's two ways that
you're going to encounter out there to
actually add this information at the at
the at the most basic level not at the
level of where the library had submitted
data or where digital archives had made
a data
when you're working with files you can
either put the meta data inside the file
for example when you open up a Microsoft
Word you can click on file and go to
properties is going to open up that
window and that's where you put the
information and that made the data and I
was going to be stored in the file the
other option is to have a tool itself
that adds the metadata for you and the
and keeps them at a data separate for
from the item so in this particular case
is an example from cetera so that's
important to keep in mind because the
search strategies that you're going to
use in the future have to revolve around
where that where that metadata is
whether it's inside the file or it's
outside the file then I'll give you some
tips about that in the the next at the
end but for now I just want you to
imprint this on your brain don't wait to
ride the metadata every time you find a
little bit an object that you want to
examine add tomato data right right
there if you postpone it you will
accumulate a bunch of files and you're
not gonna feel like doing them you're
not going to find the time to do it and
this is going to make your life
impossible trust me I I took a while to
finish grad school and it was mostly
because I spent three years organizing
my maid of data that might be an
exaggeration but uh all right that only
leaves the that the question of whether
it's going to be there or not in the
future and I think Bob gave some very
good tips on how to preserve it I think
I can summarize it in the in the next
slide which is there is four options
that I that I think should be on
everybody's a workflow right now so you
start with you get you work on your pc
right and you're going to have to
external hard drives one in your in your
house and the other one in Alaska the
reason is because of fires you don't
want to have that hard disk inside your
house and also this is the hard drive
where you you back up to once a year
only you don't have you this is not the
one that your back up once every week so
in the one of your house you back up
once a week but they're the same thing
you also have a cloud backup so you have
some kind of service that extracts the
data amazon is the one that is pretty
good and they do it automatically you
tell them what folder
you want them to grab every month you
don't have to worry about it it works
the same for the your external hard
drive you don't have to remind yourself
this this can be done automatically and
of course there's the another form of
backup but it's not considered backup
which is the sinking across different
machines that is itself a good strategy
to have beside your regular backups
because it means that my my laptop in
the office is going to have the same
files as the laptop at home and actually
with the cloud sync in the registers
Dropbox I actually have those files also
online so it's different than the clout
than the backup of the cloud but it's
but it's just as an extra security step
so chances are I'll not lose my my data
and because of the cloud syncing and the
cloud backup the data can survive even
and despite of the machines it goes the
hard drives might die but the cloud the
cloud people they are committed you're
paying the money so that they can keep
that data alive or at least a safe from
by trot but probably not safe from you
know a file format that goes out of
existence so everything that boss said
was very relevant to this so the problem
is there's too many tools to do research
and by extension to do archiving and
there are too many too many file types
so the idea here is you get a you pick
this up with experience I don't know if
there's any hard-and-fast rule to do
this I can of course me with anybody and
and give him some some tips depending on
the project but the one a bit of Chinese
cookie wisdom that you want to take with
you is that you always want the right
tool for the right job this is something
Rebecca Kinnison will also tell you all
the time right tool for the right job
yeah and by job I mean here projects so
I work with projects maybe maybe people
can organize their lives around projects
i always have different projects and
different projects have for me a
different set of combination of tools
that work really well for that
I wouldn't recommend applying the same
tools to the same projects for many
reasons and one of the things that I did
and I want to spend my last two minutes
or one minute talking about is a sample
project this is the workflow that I used
to work on my dissertation so I always I
use Evernote to kind of just think
through a problem and never know it is
good because you can web clip from the
web you can take down anything but also
you can annotate it you can write a
little notes a little picture sound
bites whatever but then that stuff it's
only organized by tags so sorting
through it like I said you have to use
the right meta data sorting through it
will require you to be able to search
for the right keywords that you were
thinking through eventually when I start
drafting then I put a put it into a tool
that's meant for writing papers sottero
it's a bibliographic to happens to
handle the same file types as Evernote
so I can take a PDF you can take a
microsoft word document you can take
most of the common file types that you
guys are familiar with so it's very easy
for me than to just take the stuff that
I want from that Evernote from that soup
organic soup that I made in Evernote and
more or less give it shape after that
then I do the project I am ready to send
that then copies of my sottero database
to to the four corners of the earth
actually not after while I'm doing it
there've got there that Zotero database
with the files with my notes with the
metadata is the thing that it's being
backed up so this is just one example
you can do this in so many different
ways the important thing is that you
figure it out exactly the right
configuration for your job so come talk
to me after if you have questions of
what this might be for your problem
thank you I'm Nick Patterson music
librarian in the music and arts library
and we're going to take a little detour
into the world of audio file formats and
archiving
and we're going to look backwards a
little bit because we've been looking so
far at things that are already in
digital form and and this is on digital
archiving but a lot of the questions
that come up these V audio are actually
to do with transferring items from the
old analog world into digital formats
and storing them and i'm going to say
much of the same that my colleagues have
also said it's beginning to feel a
little bit like a revival meeting we're
all like i have an archiving problem and
i'm here today to talk to you about it
so here are some of the formats that we
have to deal with and these are things
that come up off and in the music
library we see magnetic reel-to-reel
tape we have LP vinyl LPs digital audio
tape VHS video tape cassettes 8tracks
i'm happy to say we've managed to keep
out of the collection so far so we don't
have to deal with those I'm and some
other esoteric formats down in the
bottom there but the key things to think
about with audio and video are the audio
formats themselves for both the analog
and the digital files the when we're
going back into the analog world we have
to think about the playback equipment
that's going to be able to bring those
formats into the digital realm so that's
a major thing to think about the
encoding equipment which we're going to
use to actually do the digital files
from analog sources and that brings up
the issue of storage requirements
because a lot of these audio and video
files are massive especially video I'll
just put a disclaimer in here that video
is not really my expertise it's kind of
just along for the ride here a lot of
the issues are the same but most of the
tools i'm going to be talking about
today are specific to audio and then
lastly there's the issue you've heard
about of metadata which is critical for
all of these various digital archiving
things so triage my first suggestion
here echoes what you've heard already
which is that i think the critical thing
is to decide out of the files you have
which are the ones that are really
important to preserve I think for audio
most of us probably have the experience
where we have you know casual listening
files
may have downloaded that we don't really
care if they're on next summer but we
then have things that might be oral
histories or family audio that we might
want to have in 20 or 30 years so you're
going to make different choices based on
the actual type of material that you're
looking at and I think one of the most
important places to start it's just to
do a survey of the materials that you
have in audio and video format and make
some decisions about what's critical
what's casual you don't really care
about losing it in the year to medium
you want to keep it for a couple years
you may want to refer to it and then
critical you have to have that you're
going to make different decisions in
archiving based on those things and not
everything makes it out alive this is
okay folks we can we can all agree that
it's okay to let some of this stuff go I
mean from personal experience I think
it's important to you know parse your
content and realize because otherwise
it's really honestly an unmanageable
task you have to identify the stuff
that's really critical and be prepared
to let some of it suffer from natural
bit rot decay and it's going to go okay
so going back to the split between born
digital and analog just different
considerations analog older audio has
special things that have to be thought
about the conditions of the originals
have to be taken into account in many
cases analog formats it may be the last
time you're able to actually play the
cassette the tape the LP so you need a
strategy in advance to be prepared to
capture that at the time of playback and
that may be the last opportunity you
have to do it so that brings in the
issues of playback equipment we've
actually over in the library just had
both of our cassette decks fail we have
thousands of cassettes and off-site
storage South Asian music I've just been
shopping for pro quality cassette decks
and they're very very hard to get now
you can still get consumer-grade combo
players but the professional audio decks
are getting already almost impossible to
find so something to think about making
decisions on the encoding rates for the
audio that you're going to be capturing
if you're dealing with analog formats is
important we'll talk about that little
later and then once again metadata
capture going back to what Alex was
saying make sure at the time of doing
this you know if it's ant be playing the
piano in 1945 you know future
generations aren't going to know that so
write it down get it in there throw
stuff which is born digital already you
have basically the file format in which
you've received the document is what you
have to live with if you are actually
creating the digital file then the same
things apply in terms of choosing your
bitrate and your sample rate and all
that kind of thing and then lastly the
our favorite thing drm digital rights
management schemes which thankfully seem
to be fading over time but it is
something that we have to think about in
terms of files that you may have
purchased that have restricted uses you
can only use it on this machine you
can't copy it to that machine these are
things that come up sometimes when
you're trying to deal with backup issues
and some of these files and being able
to access them from different locations
having authorized computers authorites
files and then both formats require
thinking about storage the metadata
again will hammer that home and access
and file management going back to what
bob was saying earlier about naming I
think we can all agree on naming
conventions for files really important
to put something in the name we may all
have had the experience with an iTunes
file where you know the metadata wasn't
in there in the first the tags weren't
there the metadata wasn't there in the
file says you know you know great jam or
something and that's all you have so
that's kind of a sad state some of you
may be familiar with this already but I
want to discover these basics in case
you haven't heard of these so when
you're dealing with audio encoding for a
digital storage you have two basic
methods of encoding you have lossy
formats and lossless formats and they
are just what they sound like lossy
means that some of the information in
the audio recording is actually lost
during the process of encoding the
reason that you do it is because you
want smaller file size so that would be
the classic is mp3 it uses certain
psychoacoustic techniques to try and
make the file sound the same but by
getting rid of a lot of extraneous
material that you can get away with and
have something which is still in the
zone
AAC Apple's format is also a lossy
format vorbis which is a kind of
esoteric a bit of a hacker format but
it's around and there's several other
lossy formats so with any of those if
you're dealing with audio that you are
creating you want to be thinking about
probably not using those to create your
initial files you want to do that in a
lossless format and those examples would
be wav aiff those are the two most
common Apple has a lossless format flac
is a popular format which you'll see
with a lot of internet-based albums that
are being made available in the lossless
format or often provided that way and
lastly this is one that many people may
not have heard of but is interesting to
know about which is the broadcast WAV
file this is an archival format and the
thing that's good about it is that it
allows you to put metadata in the audio
file itself we need some esoteric tools
to do it but you are able to actually
get metadata in the audio file as part
of the file not as an external thing out
so sample and bit rates what you hear of
a CD quality actual real CD quality is
44.1 kilo Hertz 16-bit quality you'll
see CD quality bandied around a lot by
vendors and when they don't actually
mean that at all they mean some
streaming format so you have to pay
attention to these things which is why
i'm featuring them here today just be
aware of the issue of sample rates and
bit rates when you're choosing to encode
something and the example i will use as
itunes since most people probably use
itunes there are default settings for
how that stuff is being encoded as an
mp3 when you create it you may not be
aware of that but they are settings in
there which you can go in and you can
tweak now there are some limits to what
you can do with mp3 but if you don't
touch it it's probably not going to pick
the best output if you go into
preferences you can go in and set those
two more optimal things a lot of
recordings are now being released in 96k
24-bit which is more of an archival and
a pro quality format again that means
your files are getting larger and then
you'll also sue this c88 point
to and 192 kilohertz this is these are
kind of esoteric formats that are more
audio engineer type things and probably
not ones that most people have to worry
about for their their own stuff but just
to recap the storage requirements here
so a minute of stereo audio CD quality
is 10 megs so we're very quickly filling
up stuff now drives are getting bigger
and bigger all the time it's it's easier
to do but it's something you have to
think about once you have thousands and
thousands of audio selections minute of
stereo audio at mp3 depends on your
encoding options that you take so
ranging from 240 k up to 2.3 Meg's so
that's a significant factor in terms of
size and something to think about when
we enter the world of video things get
scary digital video 200 megs per minute
HD 10 gigs so astronomical astronomical
announced that's with stereo audio in
enjoying to the audio iTunes is the
gorilla in the room how many of you use
itunes to do your personal audio file
management I actually fewer than I
thought interest I know now they're
they're just slow hands coming up slowly
here so that's your audio file looking a
little a little worried that it may not
survive this process so itunes i just
wanted to mention a couple things that
you know may not be obvious in itunes
you may know this already but forgive me
for just going through these things the
default setting for audio encoding which
i mentioned is under preferences you
should take a look there and see what is
set you can choose in what file format
itunes is ripping audio from either a CD
source or whatever you're flying into it
usually out of the box i think it's set
to AAC is Apple's preferred preferred
format but there may be situations in
which you want to pull that audio in at
actual CD quality and you'll have to go
in there and change that preference to
aiff or wave for that so that's just
something to think about you have to be
prepared to deal with the file sizes
with that but it's recommended basically
to capture your audio at the high
quality you can and then if you want
essentially a service copy to take on
your iPod or use in some other context
shrink it down have two copies but get
your original copy at the highest
possible sample rate and bitrate that
you can I personally use some hacks
small hacks and iTunes just to live with
the file structure that they force you
into I like to use the comments field to
put in my own text that I want to be
able to search for this is more of an
organizational things kind of a pre
archiving thing than an actual archiving
thing but you can use free text in
comments and use it to retrieve whatever
files you want you can use the asterisk
or some symbol or some text and it will
be searchable as a keyword but you do
have to have comments turned on as a
view option in your list of iTunes
tracks in order to retrieve it so just
bear that in mind all of the tags that
you have access to if you've ever done
looked at the info and an itunes track
there that is metadata you're able to
put that in when you put a CD in and it
pull stuff down it will actually go and
pull stuff from grace note or some place
on the web to try and get the tracks in
if you've noticed if you're offline that
you're not getting actual tracks that's
because it's there's nowhere for it to
pull from so get in there and hand code
as much as possible if you if you have
the spirit to do that you're going to
get the best quality metadata by going
in and hand coding there you can also
work on several files at the same time
so some best practices very quickly for
high fidelity music 96k 24-bit is a good
standard to have just in terms of
capturing your audio if you're working
from a CD there's no point in going
higher than the CD is already you may as
well just use the 44.1 16-bit that's the
existing top level just realize that
every time you step down or encode in a
lossy format you're losing stuff which
can no longer be retrieved you can't
step back up so every time you go down
you're losing a step of that fidelity
and you want to at least keep your
original archived copy and the highest
quality
encoding that you can for some material
like spoken word and older historical
audio you can get away with lower
frequency recording if size is really
important in your in your storage issues
but if you don't have to it doesn't hurt
just to have a uniform you know high
quality format once again broadcast wav
file allows you to put metadata in the
audio file itself it's pretty geeky it's
only if you have really serious archived
audio that you may want to get into it
and keep things like edit logs of what
you did to the file how you processed it
when it was done stuff like that back up
again evangelism external high drive and
preferably to mean mean time between
failures so I got that wrong but it is
failure drives will fail inevitably you
can be guaranteed of that so keep
migrating the stuff i personally use an
external drive a second drive not in
Alaska because I'm not as why is this
allexus but the cloud is also an
important part of that i will say that
on the uploading is a little tricky i'm
going to ask alex for pointers about
that later because large file sizes
there are some issues with getting the
stuff up there and for really really
important stuff the broadcast wave file
format also allows you to do a checksum
on the file which is really critical
stuff if you want to make sure that when
you're moving it between these various
locations that it's a bit perfect copy
that nothing has changed in moving from
one place to the other this is getting
into forensic audio stuff but for the
really critical stuff it can be
important over time that can corrupt
files so that's the last thing there and
then I just closed with a couple
resources here very quickly we'll just
go through the digital music lab in the
music and arts library we have equipment
that may assist you in some of this work
we have audio editing we have software
to do encoding of original stuff if you
have format transfers we have cassette
and LP equipment that you can encode
stuff with their batch processing which
Bob mentioned is possible for renaming
files and also processing files in
batches for iTunes Doug's Apple scripts
if you're not familiar with them or a
good thing to know there's lots of user
contributed Apple script
that do a lot of useful things that
iTunes is unable to do or unwilling to
do and then bwf meta edit is an open
source project for for working with
broadcast WAV files lossless editing for
mp3s and music metadata source sorry I
think I've gone a little over time but
that's that's it for me
hello ah i would also see there is quite
a bit of redundancy in our presentation
i'll try to skip through the stuff that
i think other people already mentioned
but one thing that is ah that i want to
emphasize is that many right now you are
actually encountering with volatility
and the importance of the digital
materials most people become aware of
what archivists the deal with historical
documents have been aware already for
many many years and decades that how
just how unstable the information is and
what exactly the necessary techniques
and methods are in order to keep it
there and keep it accessible so in a way
we find the movie work with digital
files the more we find out that all the
tools were developed for just
intellectual tools that we find that we
developed for analog collections
actually fit quite well into the digital
realm and I mostly would like to share
them with you because I more or less
your own you all are your own archivists
by now so just so you see what is in the
electronic records and special
collections right now it is from
columbia university is of course the
digitized materials that are copies of
your old analog originals oh you know
let's say various older paper documents
that were digitized for ease of access
there are publications and research
materials that end up in the effect now
end up in the academic commons unlike
older theses and dissertations that are
in the university archives in hard
copies there are websites and there is
all kind of other digital board
materials which consist of multiple
formats with new formats coming up every
year and you know which is generally not
something you can just memorize once
because things change faster than you
can memorize them so when you are your
own archivist you just go you follow the
steps that we always followed when we
dealt with whatever collections and
whatever formats that come our way so
first is identify the scope and the
purpose of your
election which is most people most of
the previous presenters emphasize that
you know how important it is to keep
track of everything you do where while
you do it which is which is I which is
ideal but it's not always the case when
it's it's not always possible because
there could be situations when you know
something started and you didn't know it
will grow up into something interesting
or you realize that some you know social
network chatter that you you know
conducted for a while actually grew up
in an interesting project and now it has
to be saved as a part of the project so
basically while sometimes you know that
you're dealing with the gray that you're
dealing with something important and you
can't keep track of it as you go
sometimes you just realize after a while
that you have a bunch of material by two
digital materials that you need to
archive somehow and figure out which
one's of them are more important than
the others and this is basically
analogous to our archival world where we
have ongoing institutional donors with
whom we give them all kinds of
guidelines and ask them to follow
conventions and to keep the metadata as
they go along or we have archives that
we accession from I don't know a great
writers who never kept any truck well
about of his materials so then you just
get whatever you get and you try to
figure out what what's the best way to
deal with it once you have it so in a
way that's the same thing if you neglect
it to keep track of your materials and
now you want to don't panic you know
it's it's okay you just Oh start with
the first step and identify what's the
scope of the things you need to collect
then you know this if you identify it
right then you select whatever is within
your scope and what's outside then you
see how you can do minimal arrangement
and description so that you can navigate
the materials and they are useful and
you know what's the best preservation of
storage methods and then you figure out
what kind of access you want to give
yourself on the word for that so
basically you'll so they lease across
key a definition I you know paired mine
down to two
sirs what exactly is the digital
materials that you collect pertain to
and what kind of purpose they supposed
to serve and these decisions would be
defined your future your further steps
because let's say for example if the
materials are for the purpose of being
open to public and they generate new
capacity of Columbia student or
affiliate then you can let's aircraft
and academic commons so that would
determine your future ways ah then you
list you sit down and once you have the
scope of your collection you just sit
down and list everything that you can
think of the documents digitally so you
have let's say this list that okay I
want to archive everything that has to
do with my Columbia affiliated
activities and then you sit down and you
write down everything that you can think
of all kinds of documents you have that
document them so then you know the next
steps as you can hurt your data into
relatively stable formats I say
relatively because those things can
change ah and you copy files to what's
been told victor hard drive into the
cloud storage in some complex cases you
try to evaluate if it's used if it's
used some sort of complicated software
what he what you can do with it and how
much what you need to preserve and of
course you try to see if you files are
organized in any sort of meaningful
hierarchical manner if they're not you
try to do your best job in organizing it
if you cannot if you don't have time or
ability to do the tags and detailed
metadata at least concentrate on your
naming conventions because you know if
you have at least that file names that
are descriptive you will it's but much
better than nothing so in the situation
where you're dealing with a lot of
materials and you cannot do the full
scale job just do whatever job you can
that you know will make you able two
nite navigate things ah and you know and
that's for proudly called content rated
metadata basically don't panic about the
new me about the new formats or new
tools that appear and they appear on the
digital world and don't even I wouldn't
try to memorize exactly okay
what are the best format for preserve
for preserving things right now because
again those things may change and Google
is your friend and let's say if you have
a facebook account and you suddenly
realize it's important for professional
work and you want to preserve it what
you do is you google locally saving your
facebook account or Google based email
or whatever it is there is usually
turnkey solution so there is usually
more than one turnkey solution so it's
not about keeping track of every
technological development it's mostly
just listing the specific items you want
to deal with and then you'll probably
find the solution someplace you don't
need to know it upfront ah and the same
goes with for social media for your
blogs for everything that for all the
new stuff that might be you know coming
your way in the next few years so for
more update information there are sites
that have been around for some time I
probably will be around to give you
guidelines for specific formats and
details but mostly again it's mostly
intellectual conceptual work that you
need to be done and everything else can
be looked up so know me so I'd say
instead of memorizing what are the best
formats or what you know like various
technical details the most important
thing is to figure out what exactly you
want to keep and how do you want these
things to be accessed and then a lot of
other other decisions will come from
that okay thank you so because of time
I'm not going to give my full
presentation because basically what it
boils down to is that academic commons
is the place where columbia and a
columbia affiliated researchers that
students faculty can archive their
scholarly works and we you know have all
of those off-site backups multiple
backups multiple checksums we register
permanent urls in other words we follow
all the best practices in order to make
sure that your scholarly content will
survive for the future including adding
all that wonderful metadata that you may
not have done yourself in order to shirt
ensure that it's accessible through
google and
google scholar and all of those sorts of
resources as well as Clio beta the new
search and discovery tool for the
columbia library's collections so that's
really the gist of what i have to say
but also to say that as you can tell
there is a lot of expertise here in
columbia university libraries to help
you deal with these issues there are a
number of digital centers the digital
humanities center the digital Science
Center the digital social science center
and as well as the center for digital
research and scholarship and the digital
music lab you know so please visit the
library's website and you can see all
these centers and come visit us ask us
questions we've also recently launched
an email account that goes to a working
group of people in this area pd
archiving at libraries columbia edu if
you send your questions to that list
someone from among that group should be
able to either answer it directly or
point you to a place where you can find
the answer to your question any
questions from the floor
but I'd like to ask a question about the
archiving in Alaska if I have a hard
drive I couldn't actually credibly had
somewhere else outside what's the best
software solution to ensure regular
better american airlines I I have a hard
drive in my mom's house in Dominican
Republic are visited the Dominican
Republic of these months a year but of
course this time to be Alaska it could
be something your neighbor across and
later or something like that but up but
there is no variable helper solution to
to ensure the continuance so what
happens is what I do is once a year so I
have my cloud backup at amazon right so
the 1 i'm about to switch plans right
now is amazon is offering something
really cool right now with this like you
can upload a bunch of stuff so this is
the the solution for audio like Jacob
eyes and Jacob I so you can upload as
long as you didn't check them out as
long as you leave them there and don't
touch him for I can't remember the name
of the program right now have a written
down cuz I heard about it recently did
you know that I've heard of it but I
don't know the name of it yeah so so
this is one with this like a savings
account right are you gonna pay a
penalty a few or an eye all right you're
gonna take a penalty if you if you take
stuff out so what I do is then this one
the one that i have is similar to that
one but i pay more because I can take
stuff but I'm gonna go cheaper now in
this one what I just continue doing just
once a year I take it for from I take a
copy from my dropbox and just poop I
just backed up that's the other thing I
put everything I I don't really use any
other folder in my
in my computer other than the dropbox
folder i pay i paid like 20 bucks a
month to have a lot of jacob ice in
there and then i have a lot of free ones
because i convince other people but then
I have everything that I need there and
then I do have videos and audio files
that i don't have my dropbox because
they're there they're big so what I do
this is I take I take those on my
physical hard drive and then copy just
make a clone of the other of the hard
drive and is probably overkill do you
know but it's just in case that Dropbox
goes out of business I'm a son goes out
of business and they probably the least
of my promise will be my files by then
but uh that's the best answer there is
no software solution to port that stuff
out to the to the hard drive or there
may be a p2p with your mom but having
her you know run that over there is
probably not the best way to go and and
the what you just mentioned and I think
and also some of the other things I
assume we can put up on the baby
brontosaurus
oh yeah we can put a list of like recent
what are the solutions available for
like long-term storage for short-term
storage for sinking yeah even some
brands of like artists that are
currently so we're the like drop us and
any kind of user agreement surprise your
issues that may come up pieces like
everybody's sure that's a great point
and actually one of the things one of
the center's I didn't mention in the
libraries as we actually have a
copyright advisory office and they have
a great website that touches on a lot of
intellectual property issues around
scholarship and around you know the work
you create so I recommend that as a
resource just to familiarize yourself
with those issues broadly but in terms
of agreements it is important to leave
read those licensing agreements because
the license agreement with Evernote is
much different from the one with Google
for example you know Google's going to
want to look at everything you have and
drop in advertising wherever they can
and those sorts of things and Evernote
you know the folks behind that are much
more oriented towards protecting privacy
and so they actually have much better
you know standards interesting right and
drop box as well and again Zotero you
know comes out of an academic
environment so simile is going to have
you know better standards behind it but
you definitely want to take a look at
those licenses and really understand are
you actually handing over the keys to
your your files by signing up for a
particular service because you might
well be
but that's it that's the other thing too
for the for the most part so I guess it
comes down to personal preference like I
stopped caring and worrying about
whether anybody's doing a search through
all my files or my online identity or
anything I mean maybe I'm a little bit
narcissistic so it's like oh they're
looking at me but uh so I guess it
depends have but if you actually get
very more than artistic or then on the
paranoia side then things are much
easier then the yeah the paranoia comes
with a lot more legwork but of course I
can be happy to work with any kind oh
very nice her yeah I'm going to speak to
the personal science teacher lock I mean
rather than the I'm at school and I'm
writing a paper need to research news
Evernote and say something little p
where they feel but they want to talk
about which is 08 / archiving do we need
to always archive in in so many
different ways using similar different
classes what's the why is it very hard
to remember everything that we do
personally you know personal life do we
need to but I guess I'm
perspective well as a professional
archivist I don't archive almost I
archive almost nothing with my personal
life because I feel I just that's what I
do for work so I don't don't have a
photo album online or physically so I do
feel we are in a way over archiving but
you know it's basically I mean it is a
personal preference so you know people
do fall in different part you know
places and they you know narcissism
versus you know privacy in a line so in
a way yes I do feel that that's exactly
why I say it's very freaky situation is
very frequent when you don't archive
something and then just later you go
back and realize that grew into
something that is worth archiving and
that's what actually is much more i
think its iteration is much more
frequent than you would think and then
you go into this trash judge mode when
you still you know okay so what are the
boundaries of this thing that i
considered important up for archiving
because you cannot archive every single
trace of yourself every single email you
should let's go for lunch but you know
at some point you get to the situation
probably wear something you consider not
important you all of a sudden see is
part of something important and then the
question is what do you do with this
stuff that is not tagged not organized
or you know not preserved in a regular
manner so yes in this case Theseus and
course works is much more self-evident
thing that probably will be archived and
taken care of as people go and that's
the best practice but you know I just
think people don't know what's important
what's not very often until some time
some years later when they look back and
all of a sudden they see that something
that didn't think is important is
important and then you can go archive
and beg them up and as many places you
like I want to do
a funny example of that actually because
during the whole Monica Lewinsky scandal
was a moment where lots of folks were
switching over to digital born digital
photography and video for new services
and so actually after the scandal broke
obviously Lewinsky and President Clinton
never appeared together again but they
had in the past a couple of times and
there was only one fellow who happened
to have video footage of them together
so that became the shot that everybody
saw and you know at the time of what he
knew it was would ever be relevant but
but to flip that on its head I think one
of the things that really all the
speakers at hit on is if you if you
don't have a strategy for managing your
personal archives then you're going to
end up in that open / archived position
you've got everything and you don't know
what everything is so actually taking
some time to think about how can I
organize this how can i maybe automate
some of the file naming or things like
this in order to to really make it
easier for me down the road to say oh
this is what's important this is what
it's not you know not that you
necessarily need to make the decision
today about what to keep it 12
throughout but at least make some
decisions about how to organize it that
you can go back and find it later figure
out what's why important anything I
think it's sort of close they should
we're talking about you have to continue
to manage your data and the end probably
I find that I usually need something
just after I've thrown it away but but
leaving that aside so many sense of
personal do that that there is a there's
some sense and saying asking you
something am I going to need this and
then go back later and say did I really
need these things and sort of cool
things out I mean certainly one doesn't
need every issue of every paper one is
ever written because that begins to be
such clutter you don't get to what you
need the other thing though that is an
interesting problem and I think we're
just getting our heads around it as a
society so much is digitized now that
never was in the past it's as if human
speech has suddenly become captured and
and it's hard we look at it it looks
like the kind of written texts we had in
the past and we think we've got to have
all of this and it can be used as Rob's
example shows but but I think we do need
a little bit of a sort of reality check
like that your question poses do we
really need all this stuff at some point
does it become so vast and so cluttered
that it prevents us from really getting
to anything that we need yeah just
wanted to end at least for me personally
I find I don't throw away anything I I
feel like I'm putting a few boxes in a
warehouse that's that's how I feel in
relationship to the to the storage that
I have available to me for reef or pins
and then I don't run into this problem
down the line of not finding stuff
because I was just kidding about not
putting metadata I am really obnoxious
about putting metadata on everything
that I go on the important things that I
did I grabbed it but I got an also
really good at distinguishing what's the
premier for me and what's not in a
though I am able to find it later even
though it's in some arcane folder
structure just through the search box
and in that sense I don't feel the need
to throw away anything at it and the
concept of clutter doesn't mean anything
to me because this digital it's not
really a space even though I'm still
forced to use a special metaphor bit
then I don't know i I don't I don't I is
a psychological the need to throw away
stuff mania because because it's not
material it's not really a material link
that we have right now to throw away
anything that we that we have sure it's
clear
psychological need to hold on to
everything yeah yeah picture this
supposes I know for me and probably for
a lot of people were thinking about you
know the personal favors their tax
returns the photographs at the time I
know the time segment is to really sit
down think about what what your
priorities are and make a plan and
execute right I think even it's so long
you been doing that and hearing all
these things and you know you're going
to i read a few posts are linked to
various places but we've noted about
them you know if I snuck personal doodle
are Becky and there you know with LG one
person giving the example but it's not
really a rifle example for me and so
then I did I feel like I'm not I took
the time I'm still completely confused
and Watson's ID but most people mattered
if you kind of it like I just need to
start but I'm so I'm over there you like
filing your engine you know my battles
of the voter after you oh no filename
kitchen photographs are easy you just
give them the place in the date and you
know for extra credit the names of
people on it that's all you you know
it's not I mean that's actually not as
hard because it doesn't don't need to
make a perfect decision just some kind
of decision you know it doesn't describe
everything just you know enough for you
to be able to navigate it and boil down
your photographs like hundred
photographs which then you can just
click through and find what you need so
no I mean there is no perfect solutions
but in mostly just don't go into using
any spiffy new tool until you putting
out of something into that and kill you
figure out how do you get the
information out of there when it dies or
no longer can keep your stuff or were
you tired of it that's the main thing
but you know it's not it's all about
just best God's cost-benefit analysis so
don't I mean I'd say put more effort
into something that you know very
importantly going to reuse a lot you
know put less effort into something that
you might use at some point and you know
any naming convention is better than no
name
so you know that's Patrick perfect at
all just add no more complexity always
your job should so maybe you have some
recognition is but a similar sense how
do you recommend if you have say
multiple instances of a file or
something you go back and say except as
simple as a word file or something that
you don't keep different versions of it
archive all that and more complex issue
is what we were video all this stuff for
you is going to get archived hopefully
often what we did audio like being
saying it's also problems you have the
material in your head by proxy but then
you have you have the actual project
files which is in the which is a format
whatever the software you using and then
have ancillary material that you're
getting to it especially the video so we
may take these slides you might cut down
man so we have to package that all up
and then archive it together because
later on down the road we may not we
might not have all that material so
there is there's sometimes a little more
complex i'm just saying that has 15 back
up because I'm one file may depend on
hundred miles Wow absolutely true and in
audio as well audio projects very often
have you know in a modern digital audio
workstation environment you're going to
have reverb settings plugins all of
these things and many and most of these
are proprietary
formats it does have to be kind of saved
in one big ball of wax in and there's a
very real problem in the fact that
you're relying on that manufacturers
particular setup there are some options
and tools you can use the triangles
beyond that and probably in other things
besides audio video as well like open
formats open source software as far as
possible so wherever you're able to move
into that open area I think that's
recommended just in terms of being able
to survive so also serve God so
archiving the system in which you are in
which that your files exist it's also
becoming more and more of everyday
practice because people are just
creating virtual machines everywhere and
saving them something we should have
done in the night extent and the age but
now it's very easy to replicate this
type the state of your machine right now
as it is and worry about rip about being
about keeping the virtualization alive
and in the future but you should be able
I mean we're getting really good so
that's not going to be a problem I don't
know coming with videos we're talking
about a lot of gigabytes so I like I
don't have that I can't speak to out the
regular ghosts are you guys yeah what is
for how many drafts to keep that's
always been a question even with the
analog you know with better looking up
with publishers and writers archives you
know it's always a question the answer
is you decided the case by case basis
there is no nobody can give you an
answer of how many traps to keep you
know you keep like you decide you look
how big they are and you decide how many
you want to keep and then you pick the
ones that are different them to be
different enough and again you know you
don't strive for a perfect solution you
just stripe some kind of meaningful
solution that works for you for that
particular case so with the drafts
depending how big the work is and
depending on how differential different
the drafts are but you know 34 with that
with textile I don't know about video
but with text it's become so easy just
to not even worry about it by using any
emerging any number of person
systems out there imma be biographer by
trainers so and I was at and I'm of the
genetic criticism school which means
that my job is to go back into authors
archives and reconstruct the writing
process by looking at all these versions
trying to recover as many as I possibly
can and every time you're always missing
that one that's going to give you the
clue to unraveling the mind of the
author right so I will always be in that
school of thought that says please save
everything please make it easy for you
know the scholars of the future too weak
to record your games great one of the
advantages they sort of double edged
sword video and audio editing not
destructively original miles are always
there as a bar but you're all but thing
you have to think about what you're
heading in the file you're headed you
software using mentioned you know the
different acts or ancillary material
other video other source all has to go
through the same box or else it doesn't
matter that
original Wow because once you have a
finish spot if you ever want to go back
to it whatever whatever you don't have
that it doesn't matter you guys start
from scratch it you have to have the
original material but the video or they
are you all that other stuff yeah that's
the other thing this might sound
philosophical to some of you but it's
actually something that can be
empirically proven which is that when we
talk about archiving or saving this item
we're never talking about the same item
at any time that we archive we are
creating an addition a different one
there is I how you have comments there
is no such thing as lossless every
everything is Lucy and I understand why
we want to keep that distinction in
audio butter everything loses something
and gain something on the way any
process of of archiving and any
remediation that we do any transfer from
this place to another is going to add
stuff there and lose stuff no matter
what it is text video audio this is
another thing we should keep in mind
when I when we're thinking about these
things not to cuz I'll you know advocate
or preserve this idea that were somehow
you know getting access to some original
that you know just thought I make the
philosophical point please get it does
get yourself
all understand where you're coming from
with that I mean a bit perfect is
technical term and it means an exact
copy but context is missing from that
idea so I think you're absolutely right
I just like to chime in one more thing
on the idea versions because I do
creative work myself and you know you're
saying you'd like all the versions to be
kept i always find I've come over time
to think embrace loss because you have
the option to say everything I commit to
this version i'm going to purge these up
what's because i want to i'm just going
to take a stand with this version and
this is going to be it you know because
i find this distracting that the old
stuff there so well that's my own
personal practice bit I think that's a
lot of people's practice at some level
when they're putting something out of us
or public ways to want to control their
legacy by controlling what are the
versions that are left behind you know
there are so many steps and steps back
and steps forward at least I find when I
write something that the notion that
sadly at my notion about throwing things
away it's because I don't throw enough
away but I find it very confusing to
look at all of those states of something
because it's think of this power point I
did where I if they're there now three
states of that power point I want to
throw all except i'm so so part of it is
saying how important is this how much do
I really care about getting back to this
it's it's so easy to make a new version
as you yourself upset every time you
save it you've created something new
every small change you make is a
slightly different version then one
almost needs to clear some of that out
so there isn't the noise so there's a
little bit of a focus as maybe you know
was it solvent rusty that has this whole
yeah shooter virtually all right I think
Emory University yeah but I think I mean
for the price of that project you can
build a new house I mean you know it's
crazy I mean it's like one of the
example that looks really great when you
talk about it but it's not scalable at
all it's one of a kind do you wear the
MUA basically can come at work with some
other this computer basically it's the
emulation of his Macintosh whatever I
think used with all the drafts that
everything is there but this is you
cannot realistically scale it up to
let's say how we have thousand
collection of thousand different people
you can't give it the treatment so it's
basically it's a one-time showcase more
than the principle it kept coming but
it's a personal time those that I mean I
my pc with some ten thousand dollars
five years ago and now it's too so it's
but unfortunately you know the output
that we have to deal with also grows
along so it's a rare Salman Rushdie had
one small mac the director is now
generate goodness yeah for your promise
real issues you won't thank you all for
joining us today and this is going to be
up on the web hopefully soon